The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So last lecture, what we
talked about was limitations
of classical
statistical mechanics,
and what I will
contrast with what
I will talk about today,
which is new version.
The old version of
quantum mechanics,
which was based on the
observation originally from
Planck, and then
expanded by Einstein,
that for a harmonic
oscillator, a frequency omega,
the energies cannot
take all values.
But values that are multiples of
the frequency of the oscillator
and then some integer n.
What we did with
this observation
to extract thermal
properties was to simply say
that we will
construct a partition
function for the
harmonic oscillator
by summing over all of the
states of e to the minus beta e
n according to the
formula given above.
Just thinking that
these are allowed states
of this oscillator-- and
this you can very easily do.
It starts with the
first term and then
it's a algebraic series, which
will give you that formula.
Now, if you are sitting
at some temperature t,
you say that the
average energy that you
have in your system, well,
the formula that you have is
minus the log z by the beta,
which if I apply to the z
that I have about, essentially
weighs each one of these
by these Boltzmann weights
by the corresponding energy
and sums them.
What we do is we get,
essentially, the contribution
of the ground state.
Actually, for all intents and
purposes, we can ignore this,
and, hence, this.
But for completion,
let's have them around.
And then from what is
in the denominator,
if you take derivative
with respect to beta,
you will get a factor
of h bar omega.
And then this factor of 1 minus
e to the minus beta h bar.
Actually, we then additional
e to the minus beta
h bar omega in here.
Now, the thing that
we really compare to
was what happens if we were to
take one more derivative to see
how much the heat
capacity is that we
have in the harmonic oscillator.
So basically taking an average
of the raw formula with respect
to temperature, realizing
that these betas are
inverse temperatures.
So derivatives with
respect to t will
be related to
derivative with respect
to beta, except that I've will
get an additional factor of 1
over k bt squared.
So the whole thing I
could write that as kb
and then I had the h bar
omega over kt squared.
And then from these factors,
I had something like e
to the minus e to the
h bar omega over kt.
E to the h bar omega
over kt minus 1 squared.
So if we were to plug
this function, the heat
capacity in its natural
unit that are this kb, then
as a function of
temperature, we get behavior
that we can actually
express correctly
in terms of the combination.
You can see always
we get temperature
in units of kb over h bar omega.
So I can really plug
this in the form of, say,
kt over h bar omega,
which we call t
to some characteristic
temperature.
And the behavior that we have
is that close to 0 temperatures,
you go to 0
exponentially, because
of essentially the ratio
of these exponentials.
We leave one exponential
in the denominator.
So the gaps that you have
between n equals to 0
and n equals to 1
translates to behavior
of that at low temperatures
is exponentially
decaying to leading order.
Then, eventually, at
high temperatures,
you get the classical result
where you saturate to 1.
And so you will
have a curve that
has a shift from one
behavior to another behavior.
And the place where
this transition occurs
is when this combination
is of the order of 1.
I'm not saying it's precisely
1, but it's of the order of 1.
So, basically, you have
this kind of behavior.
OK?
So we use this curve
to explain the heat
capacity of diatomic gas,
such as the gas in this room,
and why at room temperature, we
see a heat capacity in which it
appears that the vibrational
degrees of freedom are frozen,
are not contributing anything.
While at temperatures above
the characteristic vibrational
frequency, which for a
gas is of the order of 10
to the 3 degrees
k, you really get
energy in the
harmonic oscillator
also in the vibrations.
And the heat capacity
jumps, because you
have another way
of storing energy.
So the next thing that we asked
was whether this describes also
heat capacity of a solid.
So basically, for
the diatomic gas,
you have two atoms that
are bonded together
into a molecule.
And you consider the
vibrations of that.
You can regard the
solid as a huge molecule
with lots of atoms
joined together.
And they have vibrations.
And if you think about all of
those vibrations giving you
something that is
similar to this,
you would conclude that the
heat capacity of a solid
should also have this
kind of behavior.
Whereas we noted
that in actuality,
the heat capacity of a solid
vanishes much more slowly
at low temperatures.
And the dependence
at low temperatures
is proportional to t cubed.
So at the end of
last lecture, we
gave an explanation for
this, which I will repeat.
Again, the picture is that the
solid, like a huge molecule,
has vibrational modes.
But these vibrational
modes cover a whole range
of different frequencies.
And so if you ask, what
are the frequencies omega
alpha of vibrations of a
solid, the most natural way
to characterize
them is, in fact,
in terms of a wave vector k
that indicates a direction
for the oscillatory wave that
you set up in the material.
And depending on k, you'll
have different frequencies.
And I said that, essentially,
the longest wave length
corresponding to k equals to
0 is taking the whole solid
and translating it.
Again, thinking back about the
oxygen molecule, the oxygen
molecule, you have
two coordinates.
It's the relative coordinate
that has the vibration.
And you have a center of mass
coordinate that has no energy.
If you make a molecule
more and more complicated,
you will have more modes,
but you will always
have the 0 mode that
corresponds to the translation.
And that carries over
all the way to the solid.
So there is a mode that
corresponds to translations--
and, in fact, rotations--
that would carry
no energy, and corresponds,
therefore, to 0 frequency.
And then if you start to make
long wavelength oscillations,
the frequency is
going to be small.
And, indeed, what we know
is that we tap on the solid
and you create
sound waves, which
means that the low-frequency
long wavelength
modes have a dispersion
relation in which omega
is proportional to k.
We can write that as
omega is v times k, where
v is the velocity of
the sound in the solid.
Now, of course, the shortest
wave length that you can have
is related to the separation
between the atoms in the solid.
And so, basically,
there's a limit
to the range of k's that
you can put in your system.
And this linear
behavior is going
to get modified once you get
towards the age of the solid.
And the reason I
have alpha here is
because you can have
different polarizations.
There are three different
possible polarizations.
So in principle,
you will have three
of these curves in
the system hard.
And these curves could
be very complicated
when you get to the
edge of [INAUDIBLE] zone
and you have to solve
a big dynamical matrix
in order to extract what
the frequencies are,
if you want to have
the complete spectrum.
So the solid is a collection of
these harmonic oscillators that
are, in principle,
very complicated.
But we have the following.
So I say, OK, I
have all of these.
And I want to calculate
at a given temperature
how much energy I
have put in the solid.
So this energy that I
have put in the vibrations
at some temperature t, assuming
that these vibrations are
really a collection
of these oscillators.
Well, what I have to do is
to add up all of these terms.
There's going to be adding up
all of the h bar omega over 2s
for all of these.
OK?
That will give me something
that I will simply call e 0,
because it doesn't
depend on temperature.
Presumably will exist
at 0 temperature.
And I can even fold
into that whatever
the value of the potential
energy of the interactions
between the particles
is at 0 temperature.
What I'm interested in really
is the temperature dependence.
So I basically take the
formula that I have over there,
and sum over all of
these oscillators.
These oscillators are
characterized by polarization
and by the wave vector k.
And then I have, essentially,
h bar omega alpha
of k divided by e to the beta
h bar omega alpha of k minus 1.
So I have to apply that formula
to this potentially very
complicated set of frequencies.
The thing is, that according
to the picture that I have over
here, to a 0 order
approximation,
you would say that
the heat capacity is 1
if you are on this side,
0 if you're on that side.
What distinguishes
those two sides
is whether the frequency in
combination with temperature
is less than or larger than 1.
Basically, low frequencies
would end up being here.
High frequencies would
end up being here.
And would not contribute.
So for a given temperature,
there is some borderline.
That borderline would
correspond to kt over h bar.
So let me draw where
that borderline is.
Kt over h bar.
For a particular temperature,
all of these modes
are not really contributing.
All of these modes
are contributing.
If my temperature
is high enough,
everything is contributing.
And the total number
of oscillators is 3 n.
It's the number of atoms.
So essentially, I
will get 3 n times
whatever formula
I have over there.
As a come further
and further down,
there's some kind of
complicated behavior
as I go through this
spaghetti of modes.
But when I get to low
enough structures,
then, again, things
become simple,
because I will only be
sensitive to the modes that
are described by this
a omega being vk.
OK?
So if I'm interested
in t going to 0,
means less than some
characteristic temperature
that we have to define shortly.
So let's say, replace this
with t less than some theta
d that I have to
get for you shortly,
then I will replace this
with e 0 plus sum over alpha
and k of h bar v alpha
k e to the beta h bar e
alpha k minus 1.
OK?
Now, for simplicity,
essentially I
have to do three different sums.
All of them are the
same up to having
to use different values of
v. Let's just for simplicity
assume that all of the
v alphas are the same v,
so that I really have
only one velocity.
There's really no difficulty
in generalizing this.
So let's do this for
simplicity of algebra.
So if I do that, then
the sum over alpha
will simply give
me a factor of 3.
There are three possible
polarizations, so I put a 3
there.
And then I have to do
the summation over k.
Well, what does the
summation over k mean?
When I have a small molecule
for the, let's say, three
or four atoms, then
I can enumerate
what the different
vibrational states are.
As I go to a large
solid, I essentially
have modes that are
at each value of k,
but, in reality,
they are discrete.
They are very, very, very,
very finely separated
by a separation that
is of the order of 2
pi over the size of the system.
So to ensure that eventually
when you count all of the modes
that you have here,
you, again, end up
to have of the
order of n states.
So if that's the case,
this sum, really I
can replace with an integral,
because going from one point
to the next point does
not make much difference.
So I will have an
integral over k.
But I have to know how
densely these things are.
And in one direction
it is 2 pi over l.
So the density would
be l over 2 pi.
If I look at all
three directions,
I have to multiply all of them.
So I will get v
divided by 2 pi cubed.
So this is the usual
density of states.
And you go to description
in terms of wave numbers,
or, later on, in
terms of momentums.
And what we have here is
this integral h bar v k e
to the beta h bar v k minus 1.
OK?
So let's simplify this
a little bit further.
I have e 0.
I have 3v.
The integrand only depends
on the magnitude of k,
so I can take advantage
of that spherical symmetry
and write this as 4 pi k squared
v k divided by this 8 pi cubed.
What I can do is I
can also introduce
a factor of beta here,
multiplied by k t.
Beta k t is 1.
And if I call this
combination to be x, then what
I have is k b t x
e to the x minus 1.
Of course, k is simply
related to x by k
being x kt over h bar v.
And so at the next
level of approximation,
this k squared v k I will write
in terms of x squared v x.
And so what do I have?
I have e 0.
I have 3v divided
by 2 pi squared.
Because of this factor of
kt that I will take outside
I have a kt.
I have a k squared
vk that I want
to replace with x squared v x.
And that will give me
an additional factor
of kv over h bar v cubed.
And then I have an
integral 0 to e 0 v
x x cubed e to the x minus 1.
Now, in principle, when I
start with this integration,
I have a finite range
for k, which presumably
would translate into
a finite range for x.
But in reality none of
these modes is contributing,
so I could extend the
range of integration
all the way to infinity,
and make very small error
at low temperatures.
And the advantage of
that is that then this
becomes a definite integral.
Something that you
can look up in tables.
And its value is in fact
pi to the fourth over 15.
So substituting that over
there, what do we have?
We have that the energy is
e 0 plus 3 divided by 15,
will give me 5, which
turns the 2 into a 10.
I have pi to the fourth
divided by pi squared,
so there's a pi squared
that will survive out here.
I have a kt.
I have kt over h bar v cubed.
And then I have a
factor of volume.
But volume is proportional
to the number of particles
that I have in the system
times the size of my unit cell.
Let's call that a cubed.
So this I can write
this as l a cubed.
Why do I do that is because
when I then take the derivative,
I'd like to write the heat
capacity per particle.
So, indeed, if I now take the
derivative, which is de by dt,
the answer will be
proportional to n and kv.
The number of particles
and this k v, which
is the function, the
unit of heat capacities.
The overall dependence
is t to the fourth.
So when I take derivatives,
I will get 4t cubed.
That 4 will change the 1 over
10 to 2 pi squared over 5.
And then I have the
combination kvt h bar
v, and that factor of a
raised to the third power.
So the whole thing is
proportional to t cubed.
And the coefficient I will
call theta d for [INAUDIBLE].
And theta d I have calculated
to be h bar v over a h
bar v a over k t.
No, h bar v over a k t.
So the heat capacity
of the solid
is going to be proportional,
of course, to n k b.
But most importantly, is
proportional to t cubed.
And t cubed just came
from this argument
that I need low omegas.
And how many things
I have at the omega.
How many frequencies do I
have that are vibrating?
The number of those
frequencies is essentially
the size of a cube in k space.
So it goes like this-- maximum
k cubed in three dimensions.
In two dimensions, it will
be squared and all of that.
So it's very easy to figure out
from this dispersion relation
what the low temperature
behavior of the heat capacity
has to be.
And you will see that this
is, in fact, predictive,
in that later on
in the course, we
will come an example of where
the heat capacity of a liquid,
which was helium, was observed
to have this t cubed behavior
based on that Landau immediately
postulated that there should be
a phonon-like dispersion
inside that superfluid.
OK.
So that's the story of the
heat capacity of the solid.
So we started with a molecule.
We went from a molecule
into an entire solid.
The next step that what
I'm going to do is I'm
going to remove the solid
and just keep the box.
So essentially, they
calculation that I
did, if you think
about it, corresponded
to having some kind
of a box, and having
vibrational modes
inside the box.
But let's imagine that
it is an empty box.
But we know that even in
empty space we have light.
So within an empty
box, we can still
have modes of the
electromagnetic field.
Modes of electromagnetic
field, just like the modes
of the solid, we
can characterize
by the direction along
which oscillations travel.
And whereas for the atoms in the
solid, they have displacement
and the corresponding momentum
for the electromagnetic field,
you have the electric field.
And its conjugate is
the magnetic field.
And these things
will be oscillating
to create for you a wave.
Except that, whereas for
the solid, for each atom
we had three
possible directions,
and therefore we had three
branches, for this, since e
and b have to be
orthogonal to k,
you really have only
two polarizations.
But apart from that,
the frequency spectrum
is exactly the same
as we would have
for the solids at low
temperature replacing
to v that we have with
the speed of light.
And so you would say, OK.
If I were to calculate
the energy content that
is inside the box,
what I have to do
is to sum over all of the
modes and polarizations.
Regarding each one of these
as a harmonic oscillator,
going through the system
of quantizing according
to this old quantum mechanics,
the harmonic oscillators,
I have to add up the energy
content of each oscillator.
And so what I have is
this h bar omega of k.
And then I have
1/2 plus 1 over e
to the beta h bar
omega of k minus 1.
And then I can do exactly
the kinds of things
that I had before,
replacing the sum over k
with a v times an integral.
So the whole thing
would be, first of all,
proportional to v, going
from the sum over k
to the integration over k.
I would have to add all of
these h bar omega over 2s.
Has no temperature dependence,
so let me just, again, call it
some e 0.
Actually, let's
call it epsilon 0,
because it's more like
an energy density.
And then I have the sum
over all of the other modes.
There's two polarisations.
So as opposed to the three
that I had before, I have two.
I have, again, the
integral over k of 4 pi k
squared v k divided
by 8 pi cubed, which
is part of this density
of state calculation.
I have, again, a
factor of h bar omega.
Now, I realize that
my omega is ck.
So I simply write
it as h bar ck.
And then I have e to the
beta h bar ck minus 1.
So we will again allow this
to go from 0 to infinity.
And what do we get?
We will get v epsilon 0 plus,
well, the 8 and 8 cancel.
I have pi over pi squared.
So pi over pi cubed.
So it will give me
1 over pi squared.
I have one factor of kt.
Again, when I
introduce here a beta
and then multiply by kt,
so that this dimension,
this combination appears.
Then I have, if I were to
change variable and call
this the new variable,
I have factor
of k squared dk, which
gives me, just as
before over there, a factor
of kt over h bar c cubed.
And then I have
this integral left,
which is the 0 to infinity v
x x cubed e to the x minus 1,
which we stated is pi
to the fourth over 15.
So the part that is dependent
on temperature, the energy
content, just as in this case,
scales as t to the fourth.
There is one part
that we have over here
from all of the 0s, which
is, in fact, an infinity.
And maybe there is some
degree of worry about that.
We didn't have to worry about
that infinity in this case,
because the number of modes that
we had was, in reality, finite.
So once we were to add up
properly all of these 0 point
energies for this, we would
have gotten a finite number.
It would have been large, but
it would have been finite.
Whereas here, the difference
is that there is really
no upper cut-off.
So this k here, for a solid,
you have a minimum wavelength.
You can't do things shorter than
the separation of particles.
But for light, you can have
arbitrarily short wavelength,
and that gives you this
infinity over here.
So typically, we ignore that.
Maybe it is related to the
cosmological constant, et
cetera.
But for our purposes, we are not
going to focus on that at all.
And the interesting
part is this part,
that proportional
to t to the fourth.
There are two SOP
calculations to this
that I will just give
part of the answer,
because another
part of the answer
is something that you
do in problem sets.
One of them is that what we
have here is an energy density.
It's proportional to volume.
And we have seen
that energy densities
are related to pressures.
So indeed, there is a
corresponding pressure.
That is, if you're
at the temperature t,
this collection of vibrating
electromagnetic fields
exerts a pressure on the
walls of the container.
This pressure is related
to energy density.
The factor of 1/3 comes because
of the dispersion relation.
And you can show that in
one of the problem sets.
You know that already.
So that would say
that you would have,
essentially, something
like some kind of p 0.
And then something that
is proportional to t
to the fourth.
So I guess the correspondent
coefficient here
would be p squared divided by
45 kt kt over h bar c cubed.
So there is radiation
pressure that
is proportional to temperature.
The hotter you make this box,
the more pressure it will get
exerted from it.
There is, of course,
again this infinity
that you may worry about.
But here the problem
is less serious,
because you would
say that in reality,
if I have the wall
of the box, it
is going to get pressure
from both sides.
And if there's an infinite
pressure from both sides,
they will cancel.
So you don't have
to worry about that.
But it turns out
that, actually, you
can measure the consequences
of this pressure.
And that occurs when rather
than having one plate,
you have two plates
that there are
some small separation apart.
Then the modes of
radiation that you
can fit in here because of the
quantizations that you have,
are different from the modes
that you can have out here.
So that difference, even from
the 0 point fluctuations--
the h bar omega over
2s-- will give you
a pressure that pushes
these plates together.
That's called a Casimir
force, or Casimir pressure.
And that was predicted
by Casimir in 1950s,
and was measured experimentally
roughly 10 years ago
to high precision, matching
the formula that we had.
So sometimes, these
infinities have
consequences that you
have to worry about.
But that's also to
indicate that there's
kind of modern physics to this.
But really it was the
origin of quantum mechanics,
because of the other aspect
of the physics, which
is imagine that again
you have this box.
I draw it now as
an irregular box.
And I open a hole of
size a inside the box.
And then the radiation that
was inside at temperatures t
will start to go out.
So you have a hot box.
You open a hole in it.
And then the radiation
starts to come out.
And so what you will have
is a flux of radiation.
Flux means that this it energy
that is escaping per unit area
and per unit time.
So there's a flux, which
is per area per time.
It turns out that
that flux-- and this
is another factor,
this factor of 1/3
that I mentioned--
is related the energy
density with a
factor of 1 c over 4.
Essentially, clearly the
velocity with which energy
escaping is proportional to c.
So you will get more
radiation flux the larger c.
The answer has to be
proportional to c.
And it is what is
inside that is escaping,
so it has to be proportional
to the energy density
that you have inside, some
kind of energy per unit volume.
And the factor of 1/4 is one
of these geometric factors.
Essentially, there's two
factors of cosine of theta.
And you have to do an average
of cosine squared theta.
And that will give you
the additional 1/4.
OK?
But rather than
looking-- so this
would tell you that there is an
energy that is streaming out.
That is, the net value
is proportional to t
to the fourth.
But more interestingly,
we can ask
what is the flux per wavelength?
And so for that, I can
just go back to the formula
before I integrated
over k, and ask
what is the energy density
in each interval of k?
And so what I have to do is to
just go and look at the formula
that I have prior to doing
the integration over k.
Multiply it by c over 4.
What do I have?
I have 8 pi divided
by 8 pi cubed.
I have a factor of k squared
from the density of states.
I have this factor of h bar c
k divided by e to the beta h
bar c k minus 1.
So there's no analogue of
this, because I am not doing
the integration over k.
So we can simplify some
of these factors up front.
But really, the story is
how does this quantity
look as the function
of wave number, which
is the inverse of wave
length, if you like.
And what we see is that when
k goes to 0, essentially,
this factor into
the beta h bar ck
I have to expand
to lowest order.
I will get beta h bar c k,
because the 1 disappears.
H bar ck is cancelled, so
the answer is going to be
proportional to inverse beta.
It's going to be proportional
to kt and k squared.
So, essentially, the low
k behavior part of this
is proportional to k squared
c, of course, and kt.
However, when I go to
the high k numbers,
the exponential will
kill things off.
So the large k part
of this is going
to be exponentially small.
And, actually, the curve will
look something like this,
therefore.
It will have a maximum around
the k, which presumably
is of the order of
kt over h bar c.
So basically, the
hotter you have,
this will move to the right.
The wavelengths
will become shorter.
And, essentially, that's the
origin of the fact that can you
heat some kind of material, it
will start to emit radiation.
And the radiation will be
peaked at some frequency that
is related to its temperature.
Now, if we didn't have
this quantization effect,
if h bar went to 0,
then what would happen
is that this k squared kt
would continue forever.
OK?
Essentially, you
would have in each one
of these modes of
radiation, classically,
you would put a kt of energy.
And since you could have
arbitrarily short wavelengths,
you would have infinite
energy at shorter and shorter
wavelengths.
And you would have this
ultraviolet catastrophe.
Of course, the
shape of this curve
was experimentally known towards
the end of the 19th century.
And so that was the basis
of thinking about it,
and fitting an
exponential to the end,
and eventually deducing
that this quantization
of the oscillators would
potentially give you
the reason for this to happen.
Now, the way that I
have described it,
I focused on having a cavity
and opening the cavity,
and having the energy go out.
Of course, the
experiments for black body
are not done on cavities.
They're done on some piece
of metal or some other thing
that you heat up.
And then you can look at the
spectrum of the radiation.
And so, again, there
is some universality
in this, that it is not so
sensitive to the properties
of the material,
although there are
some emissivity and
other factors that
multiply the final result.
So the final result,
in fact, would
say that if I were to
integrate over frequencies,
the total radiation flux,
which would be c over 4 times
the energy density
total, is going
to be proportional
to temperature
to the fourth power.
And this constant in front
is the Stefan-Boltzmann,
which has some particular
value that you can look up,
units of watts per area
per degrees Kelvin.
So this perspective
is rather macroscopic.
The radiated energy is
proportional to the surface
area.
If you make things
that are small,
and the wavelengths that you're
looking at over here become
compatible to the
size of the object,
these formulas break down.
And again, go forward
about 150 years or so,
there is ongoing research--
I guess more 200 years--
ongoing research on--
no, 100 and something--
ongoing research on how these
classical laws of radiation
are modified when you're dealing
with objects that are small
compared to the wavelengths
that are emitted, etc.
Any questions?
So the next part of the story
is why did you do all of this?
It works, but what
is the justification?
In that I said there was
the old quantum mechanics.
But really, we want to have
statements about quantum
systems that are not
harmonic oscillators.
And we want to be able
to understand actually
what the underlying
basis is in the same way
that they understand
how we were doing things
for classical
statistical mechanics.
And so really, we
want to look at how
to make the transition
from classical to quantum
statistical mechanics.
So for that, let's
go and remind us.
Actually, so
basically the question
is something like
this-- what does
this partition function mean?
I'm calculating
things as if I have
these states that are
the energy levels.
And the probabilities are e
to the minus beta epsilon n.
What does that mean?
Classically, we knew
the Boltzmann rates
had something to do with
the probability of finding
a particle with a particular
position and momentum.
So what is the
analogous thing here?
And you know that in
new quantum mechanics,
the interpretation of many
things is probabilistic.
And in statistical
mechanics, even classically
we had a probabilistic
interpretation.
So presumably, we want to
build a probabilistic theory
on top of another
probabilistic theory.
So how do we go
about understanding
precisely what is
happening over here?
So let's kind of
remind ourselves
of what we were doing in the
original classical statistical
mechanics, and try to
see how we can make
the corresponding
calculations when
things are quantum mechanical.
So, essentially, the
probabilistic sense
that we had in classical
statistical mechanics
was to assign probabilities
for micro states, given
that we had some knowledge
of the macro state.
So the classical
microstate mu was a point
which was a collection of
p's and q's in phase space.
So what is a quantum microstate?
OK.
So here, I'm just going to jump
several decades ahead, and just
write the answer.
And I'm going to
do it in somewhat
of a more axiomatic way,
because it's not up to me
to introduce quantum mechanics.
I assume that you
know it already.
Just a perspective
that I'm going to take.
So the quantum microstate
is a complex unit vector
in Hilbert space.
OK?
So for any vector space, we can
choose a set of unit vectors
that form an orthonormal basis.
And I'm going to use
this bra-ket notation.
And so our psi, which is
a vector in this space,
can be written in
terms of its components
by pointing to the different
directions in this space,
and components that I will
indicate by this psi n.
And these are complex.
And I will use the
notation that psi n
is the complex
conjugate of n psi.
And the norm of this I'm going
to indicate by psi psi, which
is obtained by summing over
all n psi psi n star, which
is essentially the
magnitude of n psi squared.
And these are unit vectors.
So all of these states
are normalized such
that psi psi is equal to 1.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You're not
allowing particle numbers
to vary, are you?
PROFESSOR: At this stage, no.
Later on, when we do
the grand canonical,
we will change
our Hilbert space.
OK?
So that's one concept.
The other concept,
classically, we measure things.
So we have classical observable.
And these are
functions all of which
depend on this p and
q in phase space.
So basically, there's
the phase space.
We can have some
particular function,
such as the kinetic energy--
sum over i pi squared
over 2 n-- that's an
example of an observable.
Kinetic energy, potential
energy, anything that we like,
you can classically
write a sum function
that you want to
evaluate in phase space,
given that you are at some
particular point in phase
space, the state of your system,
you can evaluate what that is.
Now in quantum
mechanics, observables
are operators, or matrices, if
you like, in this vector space.
OK?
So among the
various observables,
certainly, are things
like the position
and the momentum
of the particle.
So there are presumably
matrices that
correspond to
position and momentum.
And for that, we look
at some other properties
that this classical
systems have.
We had defined classically
a Poisson bracket,
which was a sum over all
alphas d a by d q alpha
d b by d p alpha minus the a
by the p alpha b d by the q f.
OK?
And this is an
operation that you
would like to, and happens
to, carry over in some sense
into quantum mechanics.
But one of the
consequence of this
is you can check if I pick
a particular momentum, key,
and a particular coordinate,
q, and put it over here, most
of the time I will get 0,
unless the alphas match
exactly the p q's
that I have up there.
And if you go through
this whole thing,
I will get something like
that is like a delta i j.
OK.
So this structure somehow
continues in quantum mechanics,
in this sense that the matrices
that correspond to p and q
satisfy the condition
that p i and q j,
thinking of two matrices,
and this is the commutator,
so this is p i q j minus q j
p i is h bar over i delta h.
So once you have the matrices
that correspond to p and q,
you can take any function of p
and q that you had over here,
and then replace the p's and
q's that appear in, let's say,
a series expansion, or an
expansion of this o in powers
of p and q, with corresponding
matrices p hat and q hat.
And that way, you will construct
a corresponding operator.
There is one subtlety that
you've probably encountered,
in that there is
some symmetrization
that you have to do before
you can make this replacement.
OK.
So what does it mean?
In classical theory, if
something is observable
the answer that you
get is a number.
Right?
You can calculate what
the kinetic energy is.
In quantum mechanics,
what does it
mean that observable
is a matrix?
The statement is
that observables
don't have definite values,
but the expectation value
of a particular observable
o in some state pi
is given by psi o psi.
Essentially, you take the vector
that correspond to the state,
multiply the matrix on
it, and then sandwich it
with the conjugate
of the vector,
and that will give
you your state.
So in terms of elements
of some particular basis,
you would write this
as a sum over n and m.
Psi n n o m m psi.
And in that particular
basis, your operator
would have these
matrix elements.
Now again, another
property, if you're
measuring something
that is observable,
is presumably you will
get a number that is real.
That is, you expect this
to be the same thing
as its complex conjugate.
And if you follow
this condition,
you will see that that reality
implies that n o m should
m o n complex conjugate,
which is typically written
as the matrix being its
Hermitian conjugate,
or being Hermitian.
So all observables
in quantum mechanics
would correspond to Hermitian
operators or matrices.
OK.
There's one other
piece, and then we
can forget about axioms.
We have a classical
time evolution.
We know that the particular
point in the classical phase
space changes as a
function of time, such
that q i dot is
plus d h by d p i.
P i dot is minus d h by d q i.
By the way, both of these
can be written as q i
and h Poisson bracket and
p i and h Poisson bracket.
But there is a particular
function observable, h,
the Hamiltonian, that derives
the classical evolution.
And when we go to
quantum evolution,
this vector that we have in
Hilbert space evolves according
to i h bar d by dt
of the vector psi
is the matrix that we
have acting on psi.
OK.
Fine.
So these are the
basics that we need.
Now we can go and do
statistical descriptions.
So the main element that we
had in constructing statistical
descriptions was deal
with a macrostate.
We said that if I'm
interested in thinking
about the properties of
one cubic meter of gas
at standard temperature
and pressure,
I'm not thinking about a
particular point in phase
space, because
different gases that
have exactly the same
macroscopic properties would
correspond to many, many
different possible points
in this phase space that are
changing as a function of time.
So rather than thinking
about a single microstate,
we talked about an ensemble.
And this ensemble had a whole
bunch of possible microstates.
In the simplest
prescription, maybe we
said they were all
equally likely.
But, actually, we could even
assign some kind of probability
to them.
And we want to know what to do
with this, because then what
happened was from
this description,
we then constructed a
density which was, again,
some kind of a probability
in phase space.
And we looked at
its time evolution.
We looked at the averages
and all kinds of things
in terms of this density.
So the question is, what
happens to all of this
when we go to
quantum descriptions?
OK.
You can follow a lot of that.
We can, again, take the example
of the one cubic meter of gas
at standard temperature
and pressure.
But the rather than describing
the state of the system
classically, I can
try to describe it
quantum mechanically.
Presumably the quantum
mechanical description
at some limit becomes equivalent
to the classical description.
So I will have an
ensemble of states.
I don't know which
one of them I am in.
I have lots of boxes.
They would correspond to
different microstates,
presumably.
And this has,
actually, a word that
is used more in the
quantum context.
I guess one could use it
in the classical context.
It's called a mixed state.
A pure state is one
you know exactly.
Mixed state is, well,
like the gas I tell you.
I tell you only the
macroscopic information,
you don't know much about
microscopically what it is.
If these are possibilities,
and not knowing
those possibilities,
you can say that it's
a mixture of all these states.
OK.
Now, what would I use,
classically, a density for?
What I could do is
I could calculate
the average of some observable,
classically, in this ensemble.
And what I would do
is I would integrate
over the entirety of the six
n-dimensional phase space
the o at some particular
point in phase space
and the density at that
point in phase space.
And this average I
will indicate by a bar.
So my bars stand for
ensemble average,
to make them distinct from
these quantum averages
that I will indicate
with the Bra-Kets.
OK?
So let's try to do the analogue
of that in quantum states.
I would say that, OK, for a
particular one of the members
of this ensemble,
I can calculate
what the expectation value is.
This is the
expectation value that
corresponds to this observable
o, if I was in a pure state psi
alpha.
But I don't know
that I am there.
I have a probability,
so I do a summation
over all of these states.
And I will call that expectation
value ensemble average.
So that's how
things are defined.
Let's look at this in
some particular basis.
I would write this as a sum
over alpha m and n p alpha psi
alpha m m o n n psi alpha.
So, essentially, writing
all of these psis
in terms of their components,
just as I had done above.
OK.
Now what I want to do
is to reorder this.
Do the summation
over n and m first,
the summation over alpha last.
So what do I have?
I have m o n.
And then I have a sum over
alpha of p alpha n psi alpha
psi alpha n.
So what I will do, this quantity
that alpha is summed over--
so it depends on the
two indices n and m.
I can give it a name.
I can call it n rho m.
If I do that, then this o
bar average becomes simply--
let's see.
This summation over n gives
me the matrix product o rho.
And then summation over m gives
me the trace of the product.
So this is the trace of rho o.
OK?
So I constructed
something that is
kind of analogous
to the classical use
of the density in phase space.
So you would multiply
the density and the thing
that you wanted to
calculate the observable.
And the ensemble
average is obtained
as a kind of summing over
all possible what values
of that product in phase space.
So here, I'm doing
something similar.
I'm multiplying this
o by some matrix row.
So, again, this I can think
of as having introduced
a new matrix for an operator.
And this is the density matrix.
And if I basically
ignore, or write it
in basis-independent
form, it is obtained
by summing over all
alphas the alphas,
and, essentially,
cutting off the n and m.
I have the matrix that I would
form out of state alpha by,
essentially, taking the
vector and its conjugate
and multiplying rows and columns
together to make a matrix.
And then multiplying or
averaging that matrix
over all possible
values of the ensemble--
elements of the ensemble--
would give me this density.
So in the same way
that any observable
in classical mechanics goes
over to an operator in quantum
mechanics, we find that
we have another function
in phase space-- this density.
This density goes over to the
matrix or an operator that
is given by this formula here.
It is useful to enumerate
some properties of the density
matrix.
First of all, the density
matrix is positive definite.
What does that mean?
It means that if you
take the density matrix,
multiply it by any state
on the right and the left
to construct a number, this
number will be positive,
because if I apply it to the
formula that I have over there,
this is simply sum
over alpha p alpha.
Then I have phi psi
psi alpha, and them
psi alpha psi, which is
its complex conjugate.
So I get the norm of that
product, which is positive.
All of the p alphas are
positive probabilities.
So this is certainly
something that is positive.
We said that anything that
makes sense in quantum mechanics
should be Hermitian.
And it is easy to check.
That if I take this
operator rho and do
the complex conjugate,
essentially what happens
is that I have to
take sum over alpha.
Complex conjugate of p
alpha is p alpha itself.
Probabilities are real numbers.
If I take psi alpha psi alpha
and conjugate it, essentially
I take this and put it here.
And I take that and
put it over there.
And I get the same thing.
So it's the same thing as rho.
And, finally, there's
a normalization.
If, for my o over here in
the last formula, I choose 1,
then I get the
expectation value of 1
has to be the trace of rho.
And we can check that
the trace of rho,
essentially, is
obtained by summing over
all alpha p alpha, and the dot
product of the two psi alphas.
Since any state in
quantum mechanics
corresponds to a unit
vector, this is 1.
So I get a sum over
alpha of p alphas.
And these are
probabilities assigned
to the members of the ensemble.
They have to add up to 1.
And so this is like this.
So the quantity that
we were looking at,
and built, essentially, all of
our later classical statistical
mechanics, on is this density.
Density was a probability
in phase space.
Now, when you go to
quantum mechanics,
we don't have phase space.
We have Hilbert space.
We already have a
probabilistic theory.
Turns out that this
function, which
was the probability in
phase space classically,
gets promoted to this matrix,
the density matrix, that has,
once you take traces and
do all kinds of things,
the kinds of properties that
you would expect the probability
to have classically.
But it's not really
probability in the usual sense.
It's a matrix.
OK.
There is one other thing
element of this to go through,
which is that
classically, we said
that, OK, I pick
a set of states.
They correspond to some density.
But the microstates are
changing as a function of time.
So the density was changing
as a function of time.
And we had Liouville's
theorem, which
stated that d rho by d t
was the Poisson bracket
of the Hamiltonian with rho.
So we can quantum
mechanically ask,
what happens to
our density matrix?
So we have a matrix rho.
I can ask, what is the time
derivative of that matrix?
And, actually, I will
insert the i h bar here,
because I anticipate
that, essentially,
rho having that form, what I
will have is sum over alpha.
And then I have i h bar d by
dt acting on these p alpha psi
alpha psi f.
So there rho is sum over alpha
p alpha psi alpha psi alpha.
Sum over alpha p alpha
I can take outside.
I h bar d by dt acts
on these two psis
that are appearing a
complex conjugates.
So it can either, d by dt,
act on one or the other.
So I can write this
as sum over alpha p
alpha i h bar d by dt acting
on psi alpha psi alpha, or i,
or psi alpha, and then i h bar d
by dt acting on this psi alpha.
Now, i h bar d by
dt psi alpha, we
said that, essentially, the
quantum rule for time evolution
is i h bar d by dt
of the state will
give you is governed by h
times acting on psi alpha.
If I were to take the complex
conjugate of this expression,
what I would get
is minus i h bar
d by dt acting on
psi that is pointing
the other way of our
complex conjugation
is h acting on the psi
in the opposite way.
So this thing is minus psi
alpha with h f acting on it.
OK.
So then I can write the whole
thing as h-- for the first term
take the h out front.
I have a sum over
alpha p alpha psi alpha
psi alpha, minus, from this
complex conjugation-- here, h
is completely to the right--
I have a sum over alpha
p alpha psi alpha psi alpha.
And then we have h.
Now, these are again
getting rho back.
So what I have established
is that i h bar, the time
derivative of this
density matrix,
is simply the commutator
of the operators h and o.
So what we had up here was the
classical Liouville theorem,
relating the time derivative
of the density in phase space
to the Poisson bracket with h.
What we have here is the
quantum version, where
the time derivative
of this density matrix
is the commutator of rho with h.
Now we are done, because what
did we use this Liouville for?
We used it to deduce that if
I have things that are not
changing as a function of time,
I have equilibrium systems,
where the density is invariant.
It's the same.
Then rho of equilibrium not
changing as a function of time
can be achieved by simply
making it a function of h.
And, more precisely, h
and conserved quantities
that have 0 Poisson
bracket with h.
How can I make the
quantum density matrix
to be invariant of time?
All I need to do is to ensure
that the Poisson bracket
of that density with
the Hamiltonian is 0.
Not the Poisson
bracket, the commutator.
Clearly, the commutator
of h with itself is 0.
Hh minus hh is 0.
So this I can make
a function of h,
and any other kind
of quantity also
that has 0 commutator with h.
So, essentially, the quantum
version also applies.
That is, the quantum
version of rho equilibrium,
I can make it by
constructing something
that depends on
the Hilbert space
through the dependence
of the Hamiltonian
and on the Hilbert space and any
other conserved quantities that
have 0 commutator also
with the Hamiltonian.
So now, what we
will do next time
is we can pick and choose
whatever rho equilibrium
we had before.
Canonical e to the minus beta h.
We make this matrix to
be e to the minus beta h.
Uniform anything, we
can just carry over
whatever functional dependence
we had here to here.
And we are ensure
to have something
that is quantum
mechanically invariant.
And we will then interpret
what the various quantities
calculated through that
density matrix and the formulas
that we described actually.
OK?